(applause)
- One thing you may not know
about me, is that I am
obsessed with cookbooks.
I read two or three a week,
and I have an entire collection at home.
I'm talking floor-to-ceiling shelves.
By the way, that's one corner.
There's like many more walls of it, okay?
So I wanna create a place,
where we can all share our
love of cookbooks together.
So this is Cookbook Club.
(audience applauds)
Oh, I kind of couldn't have wished
for a more incredible person
to kick this signature segment off with.
He is a legend in the food world,
and has the biggest heart ever.
His organization, World Central Kitchen,
has served more than
40 million fresh meals,
to people around the world impacted by,
natural disasters and other crises.
Please welcome the incredible José Andrés.
(audience applauds)
- Hello Drew.
How are you?
- Oh my God.
I am such an Uper fun.
So this is our first Cookbook Club.
(audience applauds)
And this came out last year.
I already have this in my collection.
And can you talk about the cookbook
that you're going to
suggest for Cookbook Club,
so that you're gonna turn us all on too.
- Thank you for showing that.
But one of my favorite cookbooks,
I love history,
and I have a big collection of all books,
but for me what's very
important as an immigrant,
to learn more about the history of America
through its cooking.
And this is my favorite.
"The Food of a Younger Land"
of Mark Kurlansky.
If you wanna know what America was eating
at the beginning of the 1900s,
here is a compilation
of stories, essays,
that he found in the
Library of the Congress.
Because after the WPA,
the Works Progress Administration,
I'm too young to be
alive when that happened,
they created a group called America Eats.
Where they were paying
writers to document,
what traditions were,
all across the 50 States.
So here you're gonna be finding
amazing stories of America,
that America doesn't know about.
- So it's an origin book,
a historical book,
and a book with recipes.
I think this is an incredible way,
a profound way if you will,
to kick off the book club.
(audience applauds)
Okay, you are such an
important person on this planet
with what you're doing with your life.
- Well, let me tell you Drew,
thank you, but I'm no hero.
I'm just one cook,
that I'm very lucky to be
surrounded by amazing people.
Many of them cooks, and
chefs, and volunteers that,
through the world, when there is a fire,
we show up.
We believe that sometimes,
a plate of food,
can be the beginning of a better tomorrow.
So you will see us after hurricanes,
earthquakes, explosions,
and quite frankly I have a
team that I don't deserve.
And I'm so honored to be next to them,
trying to provide food to people in need.
- Well listen,
really, you are a game
changer for our planet.
The way you show up for people,
the effectiveness,
the galvanizing and organizing,
the doing that you do,
it is a true game changer.
- Sometimes when you need
people to take care of
in hurt,
after a hurricane, you
send doctors and nurses.
When you need to rescue people,
you send first responders
and firefighters.
When you need to feed
people, who you should send?
Well, this is simple.
It's cooks like me, all around America,
all around the world,
that we put our know-how to feed,
not only the few in our restaurants,
but to try to feed the
many after disasters.
Simple.
- Well, you are a total inspiration
to me and everyone else.
(upbeat music)